presidents of the united states have
many powers but perhaps one of the most
influential of these powers is the power
of appointment they can of course
appoint members of their cabinet they
can appoint
ambassadors m
ambassadors
and they can appoint judges
we could talk about federal judges
generally but perhaps most importantly
they can appoint members of the supreme
court the united states supreme court
and that is a very influential
appointment because these are positions
that will last for a lifetime
but this power is not unchecked these
appointments need to be confirmed by the
united states senate
and many times the confirmation process
goes relatively smoothly but sometimes
especially when we're talking about
lifetime judicial appointments
especially to the united states supreme
court things can get quite heated and
perhaps the best example of that is
something that has happened quite
recently relative to the making of this
video
2016 was an election year
in february of 2016 you have associate
justice scalia passes away now this is a
really really big deal because as we
talked about supreme court appointments
are for life and so in theory this is
now a time where the president would
make a nomination
now the president does make a nomination
president barack obama in march of 2016
nominates merrick garland
now the republicans are not happy and
republicans control both houses of
congress but most important for this
video they control the senate and the
reason why they are not happy is justice
scalia was considered to be the
conservative backbone of the united
states supreme court and if all of a
sudden he is replaced with someone who
leans to the left who leans liberal
that could change the tone that could
change the
the sentiment of the united states
supreme court for a generation or maybe
even generations to come
so they invoke their power in the senate
which is controlled by mitch mcconnell
who's the senate majority leader he
decides to take a hard stance and even
though president obama had nominated
america garland the republicans make the
argument that hey this is a presidential
election year we're just going to wait
things out so they refuse to have
hearings on merrick garland much less
vote on his nomination and so they
essentially just wait out the clock
through the presidential election and
then at the presidential election you
have a republican gets elected donald
trump and so then they are able to help
get donald trump's appointment for that
seat approved and even that is a little
bit of a interesting political story
so this is a classic example of a
congressional check on a presidential
power and this one in particular gets
people on both sides of the aisle a
little bit worked up democrats would say
wow you did not consider an appointment
by a president and you waited out many
many many months just to get an outcome
you wanted while republicans might say
wow mitch mcconnell was really
principled here and he really used the
senate's constitutional power to place
an appropriate check on the president
i will let you decide